china has just done something
that reminds me
that even a broken clock is right twice
a day okay i don't really i don't like
china
communism is evil i don't like the
chinese government it's commits all
sorts of horrible atrocities it
suppresses christianity it's really bad
government
but china has just given me i think the
best argument that i've ever heard for
defecting from the west and moving to
china
they're censoring the 1990s sitcom
friends
this look
a stopped clock right
china is censoring friends
a very unfunny show i liked friends when
it was on the air
i was a kid i would watch it everybody
watched it it does not hold up i
recently tried to rewatch it it's
impossible when you compare friends to a
good tv show like frasier it's not it's
i don't even want to make the comparison
those two shows should not be
uttered in the same sentence okay
and uh friends obviously should have
been censored long long ago if not by uh
discerning private individuals then then
by uh the state and possibly the united
nations so china china has uh censored
the show they've taken out ross's
ex-wife because she's a lesbian
they took out references to her they
took out joey's references to going to
strip clubs and they kind of changed
some of that
they take they took out all a lot of the
references to like orgasms and things
like that and made it a little bit uh
nicer uh
i'm only half joking when i say this is
pretty smart of china i'm only half
joking because while we as americans and
especially as conservatives have an in a
natural
aversion to censorship of any kind by
anyone forget the government but even
private individuals even institutions
it is worth remembering that just like
poetry requires limits so too does
liberty right
really bad poetry is the poetry that
doesn't have any rules good poetry is
sonnets right sonnets that have meter
that have rhyme that have numbers so
when you think of the great works of
hollywood ever made
they were made during a period when
hollywood censored itself when there was
something called the haze code it was in
effect from 1934 to 1968.
the the haze code produced some of the
greatest movies of all time in those
days we got movies like going with the
wind the wizard of oz mr smith goes to
washington stage goes great movies when
he got rid of it we got absolute trash
like friends
the way that it was uh came about was
that largely catholic conservatives
convinced
hollywood to implement this code and
then protestant america loved it it was
once described as a jewish-owned
business selling catholic theology to
protestant america but it worked it was
great and we had good good movies back
then and i would much rather have the
wizard of oz and wuthering heights and
gone with the wind then crap like
friends so listen maybe we can learn
from our opponents even if that opponent
is china did you know that 85 of
grass-fed beef in the united states is
imported from overseas that's right even
if it says product of usa on it that
doesn't really mean it's from america if
it's minimally processed here they get
to say that and then you're going to be
paying a premium for overpriced
foreign low quality meat don't do that
head on over to good ranchers good
rancher says 100
american meat delivers it right to your
door at an incredible price i love it
too because one the meat is exceptional
i eat it all the time the steaks the
hamburgers the chicken but the way they
packages they package it individually
there's so much meat in this country
just gets thrown out it's just
completely wasted because of packaging
this one you're not going to waste it
because it tastes too good but two
you're not going to have too much and
then you got to throw it out later it's
you're going to save money on both sides
of that head on over to goodranchers.com
knowles today solve your meat problem
once and for all get the transparency
quality and cuts that you've been
craving order now with code knowles get
30 bucks off your box
now is the time to support american
farms and ranches they're hurting your
hungry solve both problems with a box of
american meat delivered whoever buys
that meat in your house go to
goodranchers.com knowles today i'm glad
you liked that clip if you want to get
more clips ring the bell subscribe get
notifications one way to really
guarantee you get notifications in case
our friends here at big tech
don't send them to you for whatever
reason is to head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]